dos au cinéma la sortie aujourd'hui d'un
des tout derniers films tournés par
jacques villeret l'adaptation de la
bande dessinée humoristique iznogoud les
intrigues davies ir qui veut devenir
calife à la place du calife
l'histoire se passe à bagdad alexandra
garde olivier tu y es tu prenais une bd
suis vendu à 10 millions d'exemplaires
en france
ajoutez des décors grandioses créée au
maroc des génies des tapis un soupçon de
magie
saupoudrez d'effets spéciaux pour un
budget de 22 millions d'euros
a priori la recette a tout pour réussir
même le méchant iznogoud est incarnée
par la star des ados l'ex trublion du
morning live ainsi très très bon ça on
n'y avait pas quarante mille personnes
aussi méchant pour pouvoir faire ce rôle
il y avait sarkozy et moi on m'a pris
moi parce que sarkozy était très très
occupés que l'ump alors que moi
politiquement je suis moyennement
occupée
oui
alors comment ça va depuis la dernière
fois où si bruce a à ses côtés on
retrouve avec l'émotion jacques villeret
dans son rôle favori du gentil à l'âme
d'enfant
s'il fut ce que
tendu mais l'humour 10 morose c'était
avant tout le calembour cher à goscinny
or dans le film c'est un peu poussif la
cua
c'est moi ça j'aime beaucoup le talent à
rebours qui n est pas toujours
populaires et
dans iznogoud des habitués le lecteur au
fait qu' on y va sans pudeur et sans fil
et l'agent mais au maximum
preuve qu'une bd au ciné c'est toujours
aussi difficile à adapter si même louis
de funès qui rêvait du rôle avait
renoncé il me woods n'était jusqu'à
présent qu'un des saint louis quand j'ai
fini scénario et j'ai eu un mois
d'attentes avant de leur remettre
scénario parce que j'avais les jetons de
de leur donner je voulais pas que je
voulais pas les trahir j'avais vraiment
envie qu'ils soient heureux du scénario
qui retrouvent leur vie tout ce qu'ils
avaient mis dedans c'est pas fidèle dans
le sens des puristes bd mais c'est une
vraie interprétation très mille et demi
avec l'envi justement d'apporter quelque
chose à vous d'apprécier la blague 3 m
parce que c'était une blague